I've got a couple people saying we're
not audible but I think that's uh the
Zoom settings because I know that we you
can hear me and I can hear you so
um
so put your questions in the Q a box if
you have questions for uh the professor
we'll get to those later in the session
we are recording this session
and uh you will get a follow-up email
with a recording link and information
about the bonus offer that we'll tell
you about and then
if you would like a proof of attendance
for this session
please put your name into the form that
you'll see after you log off Zoom
how many experience how many years of
experience do you have that's our first
question for the audience
I'm going to put up that poll
answering the poll please
I'm going to
leave this open for just another five
seconds
okay
and I will close the pool
sharing the results we have about
45 percent of our audience who are still
studying for their degree
uh
we have everyone else is in the
workforce including about a third who
are uh fairly seasoned with more than
five years experience
so
let's move on
just let you know what the program today
is going to be about the session today
is about you you've already seen the
first poll question we'll be talking
about blockchain and potential for
careers in blockchain we'll talk about
the program a little bit and then we
will go over with you the bonus offer
and how to get enrolled if it's
something of interest to you
this focus of this section is on
blockchain
technology in the careers so
let me
introduce
simply learn we as I said are the
delivery partner with IIT compore where
the world's leading boot camp for on
digital skills development upskilling
uh five million professionals trained in
over 150 countries we deliver our
programs anywhere that you can access
your web browser so
we make
upskilling available worldwide
we transform lives by empowering people
with digital skills so we're very proud
to be the partner with IIT com for and
here is Professor Shukla I'm going to
let him introduce
yourself
hi uh so I'm Professor Sandeep
I am a professor of computer science uh
in the department of computer science
and engineering at the Indian Institute
of Technology kanpur
uh other than being a professor uh in
this computer science department
I'm also running a number of research
projects so uh one of them is uh the
national blockchain project which is uh
funded by the National Security Council
under the prime minister's office
and we have developed uh blockchain
solutions for land records and
blockchain solution for self-serverting
identity for uh tokenized uh development
rights development rights uh in the
various other things in the uh in the
world of blockchain we also do a lot of
research on uh finding uh how to analyze
uh cryptocurrency crimes crimes within
cryptocurrency and work with law
enforcement on that
uh also uh in another role I am also the
coordinator for the interdisciplinary
Center for cyber security and cyber
defense for political infrastructure
um I give my education uh long ago
before most of you were born probably uh
in 97 I got my PhD and 95 got my masters
from the State University of New York uh
in uh in the US
okay
thank you professor
and so we're going to talk about careers
in blockchain and before we get started
um I want to make sure that everybody
understands
blockchain Beyond just the buzzword so
can you
kind of give the the
basic primer on what blockchain is why
the technology uh is important so so
blockchain is actually a special case of
distributed Ledger technology or dlds
and the idea is that if you have a
prostate party like for example your
bank if you trust your bank then uh you
do transactions on your bank account but
all the uh you know transfer of money
um uh deposit of money withdrawal of
money all this information is kept by
the Frosted party which is your bank and
you trust them to ensure that there is
nothing wrong in the record keeping of
the transactions that you make
now if you cannot trust a third party
which is like your bank then what you
can do is you can develop a system which
is the distributed Ledger technology by
which uh you keep a distributed Ledger
so what you do is that whatever
transactions you do you actually
broadcast the transaction to everybody
and everybody keeps a copy of your
transaction and uh Keeps The Ledger
current so that at any time at any point
at any uh part of the system uh
information is available about your
account your transaction history and
also uh make sure that you know there is
nothing uh wrong with the transaction
history now there is a trick to it which
is that if you are going to have all
your transactions recorded and it's not
only you I I'm talking about everybody
so everybody wants to keep their
transaction information and wants to
make sure that the transactions are
valid that is if you are making a
transaction you have the adequate amount
of funds in your accounts then you have
to make sure that somebody validates all
the transactions now to validate a
transaction uh what you can do is that
you can ask everybody to validate and to
validate your transaction they have to
look at your transaction history
and uh the the issue is that how do you
keep that transaction history you can
keep it in many different ways one way
is to keep them in a in a form of a
blockchain so in a blockchain number of
transactions which are done
closely in time they are actually put
together in a block and between two
blocks two subsequent blocks there is a
connection the connection is by keeping
the hash cryptographic hash of the
previous Block in the next block
so there by doing that what you do is
you are making sure that nobody can
change uh your transaction history
because if they do then the hash will
change and then all subsequent hashes
need to be changed so therefore uh the
uh data structure in which you keep your
transactions which is called the
blockchain has the property that you
cannot easily change any any information
that has already been put in into a put
into a block uh and and thereby ensuring
the Integrity or ensuring the data
Integrity of the history of transactions
so that's what you're seeing in this
picture this picture has lot more
information than you probably need in
the beginning uh this uh blocks that are
uh that you are seeing here uh they're
showing three consecutive blocks lock in
Block in plus one and block n plus two
and as you can see that the Block in my
in in minus once hash is in Block n
block ends hash using Block in plus one
and block in in plus once hash is in
Block in plus two and this goes on uh
until the very latest
and the one more issue is that since
everybody uh you know is trying to
create this blockchain and every copy of
this blockchain has to be consistent
there is a concept called consensus so
in blockchain there is a concept of
consensus which is required in order to
make sure that all the ledgers or all
the blockchain copies are actually
consistent with each other and that
that's a pretty uh complex process and
that's where all the algorithms and all
the uh distributed protocol uh in a
blockchain uh that comes in uh in making
sure that the consensus is uh is done
securely and and correctly and all this
information that's in the blockchain can
be trusted uh because uh it is its
Integrity is beyond uh doubt
right right thank you um and that's
really the importance is that you've
you've got a way for everyone to access
everyone in your ecosystem to access the
same information
through the blockchain
but nobody can tamper with it
um because as you said to go back to
change any block would have to to cause
you to change pretty much every block
right
all the subsequent blocks yes exactly
so
that's the basic
notion behind
blockchain and
that
the applications go well beyond what we
understand as you know Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency right what is you had
mentioned some of the other applications
you developed uh for Indian state
governments and for the Indian
government so what are what are some of
the ways these things work
right so
um yeah so cryptocurrency uh was the
original uh uh use of blockchain so
Bitcoin in 2009 uh Bitcoin was
introduced and they they had the idea
was to create a currency a digital
currency uh that would be uh
self-sufficient in the self-sufficient
ecosystem in which the currency will be
created within digitally within the
blockchain and all the transactions are
accounted for uh in the by keeping their
records of all the transactions within
the blockchain however the property that
I I properties that I have mentioned
about blockchain first is the data once
once the data is in the blockchain it is
uh very very difficult to actually
tamper with the data so it's tamper
resistant uh data
second is that it is replicated because
it is replicated it is high available
ability then highly fall tolerance so
information that is in the blockchain
can be accessed even if some of the
servers or some of the nodes on which
the blockchain or The Ledger is
maintained is uh down or or has been
compromised by Cyber attack Etc and and
therefore uh people have started using
the blockchain idea for many other
places where a uh we need to actually
keep the data tamper-proof and keep the
data highly available and therefore uh
we have seen the use of these in uh for
example keeping land registry records
land registry when you register a sale
of a land or a purchase of a land that
data
usually in most places is kept in some
centralized server and it has been found
that there has been a compromise of that
server and therefore people have lost
rights to their land and therefore
people have started say seeing
usage of blockchain in land registry
record and other kind of registry
reports uh you also see uh the
information about supply chain for
example
if you are talking about covid vaccine
as it comes from the supplier through
various various intermediaries all the
way to the final point where where the
patients are administered there has to
be a temperature
that has to be maintained for the
vaccine otherwise the vaccine becomes
useless and how do you make sure that
the vaccine has never been through uh an
intermediary you did not keep the uh
temperature and and other other
conditions uh properly so there has been
usage of the industrial uh the iot The
Internet of Things devices sensors along
with blockchain and there are other
applications of supply chain uh
Integrity like for example now supply
chain are often compromised in software
supply chain so so they are supply chain
Integrity is an another such application
identity like how do you identify people
uh who do not have for example passport
and and other uh necessary birth
certificate and other documents uh
people have used blockchain-based uh
self-sovereign identity Solutions there
so blockchain is not necessarily only
about uh cryptocurrency although
cryptocurrency is one uh one of the most
prominent applications of blockchain but
if you look at cryptocurrency it's
mostly a speculation uh speculation
based instrument and you know it's kind
of deviated from its original purpose
but other applications of blockchain
such as uh you know records of registry
registration identity supply chain uh
and various other things uh are actually
uh taking
um uh shape and being used more and more
and uh we are expecting that there will
be a rapid growth of adoption of
blockchain Technology record keeping and
uh enforcing contracts uh enforcing uh
you know supply chain Integrity uh this
kind of stuff
yeah and and you know a couple of
examples from
you know how this transforms the world
one of the big problems in the United
States that's been happening recently is
that there are people who are committing
real estate fraud so somebody who owns a
home may not realize that
some
you know bad actor has gone to
the County recording office and recorded
that the ownership of the home is
transferred
and and there's the system for doing
that in the United States most places is
very archaic so
paperwork can be done without the
homeowner even knowing and
so blockchain
and this is the one of the applications
that you have developed
blockchain for Land Title records is
a way to prevent that kind of Fraud and
secure that chain of ownership
um
so that and if you apply that example to
supply chains in general and and the
idea of making sure that what you're
receiving is genuine and that it's uh
fit for service
um that's a huge thing the other example
I would show that in the United States
was a outbreak of uh foodborne illness
from
lettuce that was harvested from a farm
that had poor hygiene so
um
the ability to train trace the supply
chain of you know everything that's in
the produce section of your Market
back to where it came from and who
handled it
vital for tracing these kinds of disease
outbreaks and preventing them in the
first place so this is a a way where in
ways we don't really think of it's going
to change our lives
right and um the the growth of the
industry is phenomenal I mean the
the spending on blockchain technology is
increasing you know
67 percent annual compound rate in
that means that you know even if it's
going to be at 40 billion dollars U.S uh
in 2025 it's going to be at
um
55-60 billion dollar you know 60 or 70
billion dollars the next year and
it's just continuing to to grow uh
you're is that consistent with what
you're seeing in India
well actually uh the uh there was a lot
of investment uh going on in blockchain
technology uh uh along with the uh you
know some tokenization we uh what
vertical virtual assets uh and also uh
what is what is now being uh uh you know
quality with three
um uh companies uh we are seeing a lot
of startups uh coming up in this field
uh due to the uh you know uh uh lack of
clarity in terms of Regulation uh by
most governments uh there is a little
bit of dam uh in the in the process but
we expect that in a year or so
um after the G20
Summit in in September October this year
uh maybe some uh you know some clarity
in terms of Regulation uh in the G20
Nations Europe has already done some
regulation in the form of mica but uh
there are some issues there but once
that gets clarified we expect to see uh
even more rapid growth so so I think
that in the last few months there has
been some sort of regulatory uncertainty
even even uh but but use of blockchain
uh for uh land record title Etc they're
they're the regulatory uncertainty is
not a not an issue the issue is uh with
respect to tokenization of assets and
and also how do you transfer tokenized
assets and so on there there are some
regular uh the consultant is there
but yeah I mean uh we are seeing
um quite a bit of excitement and quite a
bit of Interest by many companies Banks
and so on uh in this in this space
um so uh yeah so uh I think I see what
you think
yeah and you know the interesting thing
about
blockchain is it's it's getting
interest from uh
I would say the popular culture but also
business culture
um where you're seeing stories about
blockchain as a field uh popping up and
various news
sources so uh
pretty much every week you're going to
be seeing stories in
business press or even the general press
about
something new in blockchain right
yeah so
um yeah so blockchain is pretty much in
the news uh we see uh well uh the the
part of it is because of the
cryptocurrency and and what happens in
the markets of cryptocurrency and and
and also various uh uh issues that uh
that are related to cryptocurrency
businesses and and exchanges and so on
uh we see every time a new application
uh adopts blockchain as a as an
underlying technology usually they
become news because uh this is very uh
novel and new way of doing things uh and
also usually uh when that happens uh it
is because some pain Point has been
indicated in centralized systems and
therefore the distributed Ledger
technology is being adopted uh so we see
a lot of news related to blockchain and
uh technology uh almost on a daily basis
yeah and we we all of course hear about
the the applications with cryptocurrency
but other applications are beginning to
creep in for um
these these types of Articles and use
coverage and here's a few quotes from
people uh who are leaders in technology
and Industry
um
it's like the the one from uh Adam
Draper who's a venture capitalist
blockchain does one thing it replaces
third-party trust with mathematical
proof that something happened right so
this is this is a way as you said that
instead of putting your trust in a
particular Bank
you have uh kind of mathematically
derived
chain of custody of of all of these
transactions yes
yeah so so if you if you you know you
have to either trust a trusted third
party to keep data Integrity for you or
you can actually create a structure a
system
which has which is running protocol uh
that has properties that guarantees the
uh the Integrity of the data about your
accounts and about your transaction or
about your Land Titles and so on so I
think that uh there is uh uh you know
especially in countries where uh
corruption is is very level is very high
there uh it is uh actually uh being uh
seen as uh a technological uh solution
to some of the product practices uh that
uh uh you know uh people have lost trust
in the institutions uh and therefore uh
you basically replace the institutional
fast or buying uh algorithms and and uh
and protocols yeah that ties in with the
the next quote uh the blockchain is a
shift of power
to the edges of the networks from these
Central institutions where you used to
have to trust in that last example the
bank now you have a
centers of trust moved out
and the the next quote is is
reiterates what we said about
the wide variety of
applications for blockchain so anything
that's a supply chain according to the
CEO of IBM anything that's a supply
chain where things move by transactions
or by
um
chain of custody
it doesn't matter what it is blockchain
can help
and that's that's echoed in the in the
last quote also by Fidelity Investment
doesn't it's not just Securities it's
not just cryptocurrency it's pretty much
everything
yeah so so
um so the uh now a lot of these things
are
um going to happen many of these things
have not happened to the fullest extent
here for example
um if you look at uh Bitcoin for example
the uh even though we say that it is
decentralized actually uh the uh most of
the cryptocurrency more than 70 percent
of the crypto uh Bitcoin is actually
owned by about four four entities right
so so the decentralization that is
supposed to happen
has not happened properly yet so so it
is uh something that we can look forward
to but uh so some of these things that
are said here are um are goals of uh you
know a distributed Ledger uh blockchain
technology world uh doesn't mean that
they have been achieved completely yet
thank you um
we've got some good conversation going
on in the the chat we did have a
question from sudershan and um don't
want to take it right now but we'll take
it in the Q a and remind me of that but
uh
thank you for those questions that are
coming in please put your questions in
the Q a that way we can track them more
uh easily when we get to the Q a
um so
these are some of these are skills some
of these are technology some of these
are platforms some of these are
Frameworks but these are all things
people
need to understand
and to to have some experience with in
order to be effective as uh
blockchain professionals that would you
say this is a fairly comprehensive list
yeah so so in order to get some
expertise in blockchain uh you need to
First understand uh a little bit about
uh peer-to-peer Network protocols uh you
need to understand uh what is hashing uh
what is public cryptography uh what is
private key what is public key uh then
you have to also understand uh you know
how uh uh same data can be replicated
across multiple uh different uh servers
or different computers and then keep
them consistent that is how do you
achieve consensus once you understand
that then you have to also see how this
ideas these concepts are playing out in
uh existing uh blockchain ecosystems
so so normally you study Bitcoin uh any
any course in in blockchain technology
starts with this fundamentals and then
it goes into an application like Bitcoin
understanding the Bitcoin uh how the
Bitcoin uh ecosystem and protocols work
gives you a very clear
picture of what blockchain is all about
but Bitcoin uh you know did not have uh
the smart contracts or or the way of
running programs on top of the
blockchain ecosystem uh and therefore uh
ethereum was created to actually have
programmability uh more than Bitcoin
programmability and so ethereum is the
one that needs to be studied very well
uh to understand programming in of smart
contracts and once you do that you
actually have more or less a very clear
idea about what blockchain is about and
and what the data structure is and and
how programs execute on this data uh and
uh and in a distributed fashion uh and
and make sure that you know uh the
program is uh transparently executed uh
Etc but one issue that uh might bother
people in Bitcoin and ethereum Etc is
that uh these are what we call uh public
blockchains so public blockchains have
all the transaction data The Ledger uh
uh you know is available publicly which
means that people can see what is
happening although there is an anonymity
pseudo-anonymity involved but there are
ways to actually uh you know see through
that anonymity and privacy might be an
issue so many businesses when they
actually use blockchain technology for
uh you know running their business
processes they actually prefer to have
uh private blockchains and that's where
hyperledger comes in hyperledger is a
private uh blockchain Enterprise
blockchain technology so in order no no
uh blockchain course can actually avoid
talking about prime private or
Enterprise blockchain because uh that's
where actual uh you know implementations
happen outside cryptocurrency ecosystem
so uh so that's where you talk about uh
hyper Ledger and then you talk about how
to implement business workflows and and
you have to know about networks and and
Ledges and data structure of The Ledger
and so on so these are all at the least
necessary I mean there is lot more to
blockchain technology than just this but
this is what you must know to actually
get your uh you know carrier going in
the blockchain industry thank you I
appreciate that
um
the there's different ways people can
specialize within blockchain once they
become proficient
once they have an understanding of those
skills we just talked about
you you can
uh and and you and I have discussed this
you have the skills you need to put in
effort then to follow up with uh
building projects uh building out your
portfolio of projects and demonstrating
how you use those skills
um and as you do that you can move
from one role to another right
yeah so I think that it is very very
important to understand that uh you know
doing a course like this or any other
course on blockchain technology uh does
not overnight make you a blockchain
developer or blockchain uh you know uh
expert
you and also uh if you want to get uh
employed in this sector uh the
organizations that hire uh blockchain
developers or blockchain Engineers or
blockchain analysts Etc they have they
want to see uh not only your certificate
that you have been certified by somebody
like IIT kanpur that you have completed
a curriculum but also they want to see
what kind of work you have done and in
order to Showcase what you have done in
this uh what you have to do is that you
have to create your own projects
um you know during the course as well as
after the course and make them available
on GitHub or some other place where you
can give the links to your potential
employers who can actually download your
code and and
run it you have to have a good uh
documentation and and read me uh in the
GitHub to to actually
tell the people how to install your
system and and run it and see how your
code is working uh they will they might
also look at the code quality Etc
and then uh you you will get good
employment opportunity otherwise what
will happen is that uh this is a very
sophisticated skill so uh just having
done a course does not uh give the uh
confidence does not give you the uh
experience
uh you'll get some experience because
you will be doing uh projects in the
course or or a master uh project in the
course Capital project in the course so
you will get some exposure or experience
but that is not necessarily enough you
might
hope that you will learn on the job but
usually it might require you to have put
an extra effort to actually build a
portfolio it's like it's like an artist
right an artist is not hired because he
has finished an art course but because
he has to build a portfolio that he has
to show uh he has to Showcase to
actually get uh you know get a job or
get a permission so so that's that's the
idea that I want to uh mention here
because uh uh don't expect that just
doing this will immediately get your job
once you do get into the field you're
able to move from development or
engineering roles into other
aspects you can also move directly into
things that aren't necessarily
technological uh development engineering
development but you can be uh
analyst project manager you can
understand how blockchain is applied in
different industry sectors and consult
in that direction so there's
opportunities for people
with less of a technical background to
to who work in this field is that is
that correct
yeah but uh see the the issues that the
person with the less of a technical
background has which still has to uh uh
you know
go through the right of passage right so
yeah to understand uh
hashing they have to understand uh
public key crypto they have to
understand uh overall structure of a
network system they have to still
understand uh the issue of data
Integrity uh they have to understand why
blockchain guarantees or rather you know
make sure that data Integrity is is a
pretty
um you know pretty much guaranteed
it is not fully guaranteed but you know
90 99 percent guaranteed Etc so I think
that there the somebody who can actually
go through the right of passage and and
uh go through these Concepts and ideas
they may not necessarily have to do the
engineering or or coding uh involved in
in the job of a blockchain developer
they might go then then move towards
legal Consulting like as I said that
there are regulatory issues with respect
to the blockchain technology and and
lawyers are working in that uh field uh
there could be also project management
jobs which do not necessarily require
Hands-On uh engineering or or software
development but I think that
if you want to go through a course like
this you have to uh you know
um have the grit to actually go through
the entire process
because
the type of training and experience with
Hands-On
uh techniques and tools is how you
understand what the capability of the
technology is how you can effectively
consult with people about how to use it
because if you don't have that
background
you're just creating a fantasy yeah yeah
um so
you take a look at Glassdoor for example
and pull off
some of the names of people who are
companies that are hiring
people for blockchain positions you can
see it covers a broad range and then
there's a lot of startups uh startups as
you and I have discussed are looking for
people who have a lot of experience
because they don't have the
um uh
the Deep Pockets and the runway to be
able to train people on the job but
bigger organizations do so
um these are these are potential places
to look for uh your initial employment
in the career
again
recognizing that you're going to have to
put in the work even with a certificate
make sure that
demonstrate that you have the skills and
the initiative to develop your projects
and that type of thing but not a fair
thing yeah yeah so so uh these large
companies like TCS Infosys Accenture
they have very large blockchain groups
uh so they and there is attrition there
so they hire in good numbers
small companies startups uh they
actually hired uh one two one two people
uh so they look for uh high level of
expertise so depending on what your
previous background is how good you are
in importing for example or how good you
are in understanding you know in
developing uh you know end-to-end uh
software Etc uh you might be you can
build a portfolio towards being hired uh
in startups that are doing very
interesting application of blockchain
Technology web 3 Etc uh but if you're if
you're if you're uh uh you know if you
are looking for getting trained on the
job then large companies are better
because they're very large teams are
already there so you will be learning
from uh colleagues now who are more
experienced than you
so there that's you know based on how
you go about it the the you know how how
do you want to go about it of course uh
startups have a lot more uh uh a lot
more uh to offer in terms of uh monetary
benefits later on uh if they actually
become very successful uh the but it is
also risky it may actually not work uh
for large companies you will get a
salary uh and and implements uh that
will be uh that may not have high risk
but they may not have also High Gain
yeah
so it depends on your appetite for
entrepreneurial risks
um we talked about the skills but these
are the tools
um
different platforms Bitcoin you
mentioned ethereum hyperledger and then
other specialized tools or other
extensions that in in any new technology
there's the the basic technology and
then somebody comes up with an idea well
if you could add this to it it's going
to be more effective and then someone
Builds on that and builds on that so
these are some of the things that
um people will be exposed to in their
career right
yeah so no so these are things that we
actually cover in this course uh but uh
there is a lot more to blockchain
technology uh there's a lot more uh
happening on a day on a daily weekly
basis uh new Frameworks are coming up
new cryptocurrencies are being
introduced new languages for smart
contract Development coming up but just
to build the base uh we actually cover
uh all these things in this course
and it's important as you mentioned
because everything is changing so
quickly
need to be agile and you need to to keep
in mind that you want to do ongoing
education ongoing skills development I'm
going to ask the next the next question
in our series here
um
what is stopping you and I know that
everybody here is interested in
blockchain as a career field
so I'm curious to know what's what's
prevented you from taking a course of
this type or training in this area up
until now what are the things that
you've been looking for that you haven't
found yet
so I'm going to leave this open for
another 10 seconds
you can answer more than one reason
to please get your answers in hit that
submit button and I will close the poll
in five
four three
two one
and
so the biggest concern people have is
finding
a course that gives them practical
experience things that will go into
their portfolio as we discussed
um and then
finding a course that's comprehensive
enough that it's going to give them a
well-rounded background
in blockchain and its applications
thank you for sharing that with us
here we go
let's talk about this program for a
little bit Professor this is the
professional certification of program
blockchain from IIT com core
delivered on the simply learn platform
and it's got the things that people said
that they're looking for which is
a comprehensive industry-aligned
curriculum you design this curriculum
because of what companies have come to
Institute and ask for right
yeah so uh this curriculum was designed
uh to give you a very good fundamental
uh uh understanding of blockchain
Technology illustrated by uh uh
illustrated by uh cryptocurrency
blockchains like Bitcoin uh the idea of
smart contracts and development of smart
contracts to actually develop what we
call this decentralized applications
um so uh through like ethereum then
private blockchain and and the
centralized application development with
uh with the pleasure uh the ideas about
uh basic concepts like uh crypto
cryptographic Concepts and and
distributed computing Concepts that are
necessary for uh understanding
blockchain technology and so on and the
curriculum is geared towards ensuring
that somebody who has gone through the
curriculum well uh and paid attention
and did the projects and Labs Etc will
be ready to actually learn as we
encounter and other versions of the
blockchain technology uh that is uh that
is uh you know uh coming up every day
new blockchain technologies coming up
new decentralized application coming up
new Concepts new ideas like the how to
enhance performance of blockchain using
layer 2 blockchains uh how to actually
integrate the idea of web with The
decentralized Ledger technology all
these things are happening you know it's
a it's a very happening field
tokenization of assets and tokenization
uh token token economy on the on the
blockchain so all these concepts are not
possible to cover in four four month
curriculum but our hope is that having
this very strong fundamental base people
will be easily picking them up so that's
the idea
and
it's all delivered online through the
simply learned platform which you can
access anywhere you have a web browser
uh your desktop your laptop a lot of the
materials you can
use on even a mobile or tablet
um to do some of the prep work by
watching
some of the
pre-prepared video that complements the
course but uh
biggest thing is that you have a
environment where you can do Hands-On
exercises labs and develop uh Bitcoin
applications using the various tools
that we discussed right on the platform
so you don't need to create your own
separate
system at home you don't need to
download or build something
it's all available to you right there so
that lets people
um that plus the the online virtual
classrooms where instructors take them
through these exercises
and answer questions and and make the
concepts clear that gives people a
chance to start work on that portfolio
we talked about right Professor yeah
yeah so so building your own portfolio
is very important
because otherwise otherwise you are not
going to uh be able to uh show off what
you have learned and what you're capable
of and uh this is uh very important uh
that you uh build your portfolio create
your own applications think about uh
applications where uh blockchain is
useful and and create small uh
medium-sized applications
and the the other aspect of this is
because it's delivered completely online
other than the the live classes which
have to be held at a time where
everybody joins
the rest of the work you can do
independently and you can do it on on
your schedule so platforms available
teach 24 hours a day seven days a week
you can log in at any time to
do an exercise build a project that type
of thing
um and that becomes especially important
in that final stage of this program
which is the Capstone project where
you'll build your own independent
solution to a given industry-based
problem so
the end of the process you receive the
certificate issued by IIT Contour uh
include certifies that you've completed
the 70 hours or more of online learning
and done the projects including the
Capstone project
um and you've done them to the
satisfaction of IIT conport
um this is not just uh
simply learn does the evaluation and
we certify it it's
you have to deliver it to Professor
shukla's standards so
um that plus the the ability to take
master classes and hear from faculty
from IIT comport about topics in
blockchain that's those are conduct a
lot of those classes yourself direct
professor
right so the master classes usually go
beyond the curriculum and uh basically
uh talks about more advanced topics uh
so that people know that what is what is
beyond the basic uh
fundamentals and what is happening in
the blockchain world today uh that kind
of stuff
I want to reassure everyone we're
getting close to the Q a
um so please hang on for that and I just
want to give the professor a chance to
tell you about IIT Comfort if you're not
aware with it it was established the
same year I was born so
um I find that's an interesting fact
yeah just before Kobe we did our uh
60-year uh Diamond Jubilee celebration
of IIT kanpur uh it's certainly older
than I am and
um so it is also uh one of the uh
actually IIT kanpur was the first
Institute in India to introduce a
computer science program and computer
science degree program and also it was
the home of the first Mainframe computer
in India uh we have had a very uh uh
world-class facility in terms of
computer science uh labs and and uh and
also uh we are in India's uh you know uh
biggest cyber security Hub cyber
security research and blockchain
research Hub uh and uh we of course run
the national blockchain project and uh
yeah so
IIT kanpur is is well known in the field
of computer science and in the field of
cyber security uh blockchain technology
and so on so it's it's a it's a good uh
thing to have it on your on your resume
thank you
so
for this particular program you do have
to have a bachelor's degree
good to have some experience when we say
you have to have a bachelor's degree
that means you have to have it in hand
or have it awarded
sometime before the end of the
four-month program so that the point to
that we'll verify that as part of your
application process
um it's good to have some work
experience to understand where this kind
of Technology might fit into uh the
world of work and have that kind of
discipline behind you do you have to
have a basic understanding of
mathematics and it's good if you also
have some exposure to Java programming
so
um
this is not necessarily the program for
somebody
who has zero technical background
um but if you have a good understanding
of college mathematics and if you've had
some experience with programming and con
concepts of programming you should be
able to succeed in the course is that
correct professor
yeah so so some programming experience
uh some understanding of uh you know uh
algebra and uh you know ideas of
probability Etc would help
and
or talking about the the
um just really briefly I'm going to go
through this uh this is all the things
we talked about in terms of of uh
the different skills start off with an
orientation session an online session
that gives you uh basic understanding of
what you're going to be learning how
you're going to use this learning
platform where to find your classes how
to do your projects and turn them in all
of that
um and then you move into the
introduction
the fundamentals of blockchain and it
s original application Bitcoin
um once you've got that you can learn
about ethereum correct professional so
that will go ahead yeah so so uh Bitcoin
has a very limited ability to script
create scripts to automate transactions
whereas in ethereum you have a
full-fledged programming language
capability to uh automate uh
transactions and and uh and create uh
Protocols of your own so so learning
ethereum is really important uh then of
course once since this and hash are the
basic concepts which might be covered
even before the uh than where it is
placed in this diagram and then you have
the private blockchain uh Enterprise
blockchain hyperledger and then we
talked about uh you know how to create
smart contracts in hyperboledger and
create decentralized applications
we also introduce a few other
alternative blockchains like Coda and
Iota just to give people an idea that
you know how other types of blockchains
blockchain platforms are are coming up
and then rest is uh application
development and and also uh doing the
Capstone project
we we list the master classes as
electives meaning that you don't have to
take them in order to get your
certificate but
um they are included in the cost of the
program and they add so much uh interest
and value that it would be wise to take
all of those as part of the study
um there's a few examples of the kinds
of uh projects that you might do you I
mean you will do in the program smart
contract development using hyper Ledger
Fabric and doing an example of how to
set that up
um
creating an ethereum wallet and that
type of thing so these are all
practical exercises that go into that
portfolio we've talked about yes
yeah
and
Dr shuklive of course is the program
director heard about his background
about him so to give you confidence that
this program will be done to the highest
standard
um which simply learn ads on top of that
is our program manager who uh keeps
track of uh the requirements that IIT
camp where in the professors set for us
we have somebody assigned to work with
you and the people who join the program
at the same time you do the cohort
um so that that person Shepherds you
through the program there's also of
course the instructors who are
responsible for helping you succeed in
each of the courses
um and you have the support of your
peers the other members of your cohort
as well as the the way the curriculum
accompanying resources are designed so
all of these form essentially a
ecosystem of support around you to help
you succeed
and
um just to let you know the the learning
environment allows you to manage your
curriculum see your full learning path
and where you are on it
it gives you access to the live virtual
classroom environment
it gives you access to the labs and
projects uh the the
development sandbox that lets you do
these things online
lets you do your tests and assessments
uh independently through the the system
allows you to build your Capstone
project and all along the way it keeps
track of your progress gives you access
to the proof of completion for each of
the courses and gives you prompts and
makes available to you support tools
the help desk
the Community billboard or
or
bulletin board rather for um
questions and support so all of these
things are on that platform
here are some of the learner reviews and
and I will share with you the URL to our
course page later but uh Manchu and
Ashwin and akshat Hall completed the
program
used it to leverage uh
both new jobs
salary hikes within their own
environment Akshay himself developed a
new digital coin
so uh
this is an example of how
people who take the course and are
willing to put in the effort to build on
those skills
develop their portfolio even beyond the
course uh can leverage it for success
a fair representation professor
that's a short and sweet answer okay I
like that
um
one of the ways that we help you so
after you've completed the course
four-month course we hit you have access
for six months
uh to
um
job assist services for IAM jobs so as
professor said this is not a job
guarantee program this is not a program
where once you complete the certificate
you're going to automatically get an
internship or a new job but you will get
access to services to help you rewrite
your resume to reflect your new skills
to do one-on-one interview prep so that
you can answer the questions ranging
from the phone interview to the
technical skills interviews to how to
present yourself and management
interviews and then
um access to the job portal
over that six months
and
I'm going to ask the question are you
interested
in training this program
yeah
all right
and I'll leave this open for just
another three
two
one and the pull
70 percent of respondents are interested
which is great
just want to make sure you get to see
that
and
so talk briefly about the enrollment
steps the first enrollment
sure got the right sequence the first
enrollment step
you need to know is the cost the program
cost is one lock 69 000 rupee that's
including tax it can be Emi financed
5751 rupee per month
and you can reach out to us and ask us
at simplylearn.net to find out what the
bonus offer we will offer you a discount
for attending this webinar they haven't
told me what it is but uh
usually a very attractive discount and
learning consultant that asked us at
simplylearn.net to help you with that
we'll also be sending a follow-up email
more contact information and a link to
this recording so you'll be able to
contact us that way
and our next cohort
will start soon so you email us at ask
us at sniffeylearn.net
we'll do an application review verify
that you have the
bachelor's degree requirement fulfilled
do an assessment of your basic math and
programming skills and based on that
we'll offer you admission if you qualify
and you can start as soon as this
weekend
the classes for the next cohort start at
8 July and if you take advantage of that
and enroll for this weekend
you will be able to take advantage of
the discount
so you like to to remind people that we
can only have a certain number of people
in each cohort in order for the
instructors to provide sufficient time
and attention to each person in the
class
we try to limit the cohorts to about 25
or 30 individuals
and so if you are interested I think
more than that number of people on this
webinar have said they're interested so
please hurry please do contact us right
away and just to get a feeling for that
and ask
one more poll question here
I believe it's our last poll question of
the day which is
how soon would you like to to join if
you're interested is this something
you'd like to do for the July classes
are you looking maybe August September
or are you looking further down the road
and I'll leave this open again for five
seconds or three
two one
and so some of you are interested in
getting started this week
please do reach out to us right away and
if you're looking at within three months
uh also do that because you'll want to
make sure you get a place in the August
September cohorts if you're looking
further down the road I still suggest
that you email us and we can keep in
touch with you keep you advised of
future cohorts of the program and
answer any final questions you might
have so
let's
stop
that will move on
and it's time for questions and answers
so I'm going to stop sharing screen here
very good thank you for that
um so Professor we've got a number of
questions that have come in I'm going to
take them out of the questions and
answers first and then we'll look back
through the uh
um
chat
to
have a question about English language
instruction courses delivered in English
is that correct
yeah
well you do have to have ability good
comprehension skills for English
um
fresher who's worked on golang is that
going to help them in this
yeah so golang is used
um uh in hyperledger smart contracts or
train code uh so in hyperledger it will
help but having had
um any programming experience would help
in in general so so yes uh having if you
if you have done go land programming
certainly uh that will be helpful
um we have a question somebody wants to
compare blockchain data structure to a
linked list data structure and my
understanding is that blockchain is a
form of linked list with with a
particular twist in terms of
the the hashing
linking yeah well in linked list
actually the link is uh is is actually
uh to an address
uh here the link is uh to a hash uh and
therefore uh the linked list is actually
uh talking about an address in a mem in
memory it will link you basically uh
point to an address in memory where the
uh where the uh another node is located
here you are basically uh giving a
unique identity by taking hash of a
block uh instead of an address of the
blog the identity of the block is being
being pointed to so in some sense uh it
is a linked list uh but it is quite uh
quite different in nature okay
somebody asks if blockchain can be used
to create websites and I guess that
brings up the related question of its
role in web 3.
yes so uh well we uh to create a website
you don't need blockchain because
blockchain is about keeping uh tracked
off data uh so uh the front end of the
blockchain front end of the websites uh
whether it's web 3 or or not uh will be
still based on JavaScript and react.js
and and whatnot uh but uh what may
happen is in the back end uh what we
normally now do is we normally uh uh you
know be back in processing the the data
that is pitched through the web
front-end uh is usually in a server so
instead it could be decentralized it
could be in the form of blockchain uh
and also uh in the web tree that is the
idea that the data is instead of having
all your data with Facebook or Google
you will actually have your data with
you and through uh some kind of
tokenization uh your data can be
actually fetched by users from your
machines rather than from Facebook
server or Google server and that would
give us a decentralization uh also it
will give us a sovereignty of on our own
data uh that currently we don't have
because we have to give the rights to
our data our our music or our videos or
pictures to Facebook or other
centralized platforms so that's what
web3 is all about that uh decentralized
way
thank you for that um
is cbdc related to blockchain I think
that
self-evident yeah yeah so cbdc is uh is
basically tokenization of money
so it's a digitalization of money so a
blockchain technology is is uh is good
infrastructure on which such
tokenization and and movement of the
token can can play out
we had several questions about
um
non-crypto use cases
um and you've mentioned several of those
can you just remind people
few of those yeah so any place where you
cannot uh you do not want a centralized
entity to uh keep your data or you do
not trust a centralized entity to make
sure that your data is uh is uh not
tampered with then you can use uh you
can develop a blockchain based uh system
uh for example as I said that Land Title
registry or learn record registry uh you
know instead of keeping it in as
employees server you may want to keep it
in a blockchain so you have higher level
of transparency and higher guarantee of
data Integrity so that no tampering
tampering has is evident in case there
is
yeah same thing with the supply chain or
same thing with any kind of report
keeping practices or uh any kind of
identity uh like for example you may not
want other
database to keep all your data all your
fingerprints and everything you may want
to have sovereignty on that data so so
you then in that case you may want to uh
keep the uh create a decentralized
application uh for uh identity creation
so that those are the kind of
applications that people are using
okay thank you for that we had a
specific question can you think of
applications for blockchain and space
science
uh well not as such except that
if you think about you know supply chain
uh uh in space science not so much in
the space science as a space technology
so when you are building a building a
mission uh for let's say you know a
mission to Mars so mission to uh there
is a lot of software components that are
developed by many contractors and many
uh other uh parties third parties and if
there is a compromise in one of the
components it could actually jeopardize
the mission so keeping track of the
provenance of the supply chain uh
through a blockchain could help them
it's a Technology support not
necessarily space science
yeah the um
General problem of counterfeit Parts in
Aerospace
like the industry for many many years
and if you have a substandard bolt that
goes into an aircraft or a spacecraft
and then it fails at the wrong moment
the
consequences can be catastrophic so
there's a really high value to that
supply chain Integrity problem
um
is AI going to affect blockchain
yes it will affect blockchain in many
ways for example in some good ways and
some bad ways uh for example uh right
now uh some of the generative AI is able
to generate uh some code uh smart
contracts uh it can also help you to uh
you know find mistakes or
vulnerabilities in smart contracts uh
through generative AI so that's one good
application where it can be used but on
the other hand you can also use
generative AI to actually create
malicious code that may go into uh you
know attacking uh
decentralized application so so it will
be in many ways it may affect blockchain
uh also uh you know through through the
generative AI yeah you can also do
blockchain education you can affect
blockchain education through generative
so so yeah I mean AI will affect many
things blockchain will also not remain
unscathed from advances
um I think one aspect is that
AI has no impact on the
fundamental technology is you know
nationally
walks but
but uh everything else around it there's
a whole the whole ecosystem
um
when somebody had a interesting question
when
um you
do a transaction with a digital currency
there's a transaction fee who gets that
oh so the the one that actually uh
eventually leads to the consensus by
actually creating the next block uh or
what you call miners they actually
collect the fees yeah okay
um and
just out of curiosity do you do you
cryptocurrency is a a real alternative
to government-issued currencies or an
alternative the government's concerned
to or is it a speculative investment
I well it depends on who you asked I
believe it is a speculative investment
instrument uh that's why the U.S
government the Security and Exchange
Commission is coming after uh crypto uh
companies exchanges uh for uh you know
dealing with uh uh unregistered
Securities uh like uh you know this is a
big controversial topic uh I do not see
uh cryptocurrency being an alternative
to government issue currency because
it's not tenable uh governments will not
want that because uh one of the major uh
function of any government is to
actually ensuring Financial stability in
the economy of the country uh and if if
it totally goes out of the hands of the
government then it will have no ability
to uh ensure that the there is financial
stability there is uh uh you know
control over inflation and so on so
forth so so I do not see that uh you
know in the near future any government
will allow that a few uh you know very
uh badly government countries have done
that like El Salvador
yeah later countries will not be there
difficult
would you say it difficult to use a
cryptocurrency in an environment where
the government needs to be able to
control
the volume of currency the money supply
that will so
it's not really conducive to crypto is
it um
uh here's a question
uh militia who asks how can blockchain
get implemented in an electrical area so
um
I think that's a great question for you
with your background in cyber security
of infrastructure
how do those two things work together
yeah so uh first of all uh a lot of the
concepts used by blockchain technology
are actually originated from uh cyber
security like uh cryptography uh hashes
and and things like that uh Second thing
is that uh you know uh it blockchain
ecosystem requires a lot of computers
network connection and protocols uh and
therefore they are subject to server
attacks uh they can be uh like any other
application uh software based
application uh server based application
uh you know desktop uh what station
based applications uh they actually are
subject to cyber attacks and and that
could actually completely uh change the
properties of the blockchain for example
uh the consensus process the consensus
algorithm may be attacked and the
blockchain may not uh maintain the data
Integrity in case of a serious aware of
that so so that's uh one thing so so in
some sense uh like any other large-scale
uh system uh digital system blockchain
is also uh subject to cyber attacks and
we require protection against server
attack but on the other side uh if you
want to uh ensure cyber security of
things like for example software supply
chain there the blockchain becomes The
Rescuer rather than being the consumer
of the cyber security protections and
cyber security difference mechanisms
that they the blockchain technology may
actually be used to keep the hashes and
stuff like that to make sure that there
is no supply chain contamination
similarly uh keeping logs safe from
manipulation by attackers blockchain
technology might be useful uh there may
be other places where uh you know
blockchain technology might be useful in
ensuring that your malware depository
has not been compromised so there are
many places where uh you know Cyber Sub
blockchains blockchain ecosystem
requires cyber security and cyber
security may actually use blockchain
technology for doing things better and
easier than than it could be without
blockchain
okay
I think that takes us to the end of our
questions we had some questions about
you know alternative or education
resources
you know how people can get uh
you know some of the
basic information about blockchain
through
pre-courses and things like that and I
do want to point out
that simply learn offers
uh some basic free individual courses
but they're also study uh they're all on
simple topics and if you're looking to
start a career in blockchain you're
you're gonna have to go beyond
the the free courses that you would take
um
things you would find on YouTube and
you're going to need to have
a curriculum that's delivered with
expert instructors and with the ability
to do your projects build your portfolio
online because otherwise
um
will have
some basic conceptual understanding that
you aren't going to have the Hands-On
the Practical experience that you'll
need to build out start a career
um
so with that I'm going to
go to the end of the program and I will
go back to this last
slide
so this is the time where I'm going to
share with you the link to our
uh website and to our
email address
and this is also the time where I want
to thank Professor Shukla for being here
today being so very generous with your
time and your knowledge
thank you
in the chat or through the QR code
you'll be able to get to the program
page on our website
you also can reach out to us at ask us
at simplylearn.net when you exit the
webinar you'll have the opportunity to
put your name in for a proof of
attendance for today's session
and
we hope that we can welcome you all into
the Learning Community with IIT comfort
and simply learn and we thank you all
for being here today and taking the time
out of your your day your evening
be with us but thanks again and that
concludes our webinar
thank you
bye now